[Musik]
die kunstschaffenden im creme vielen
weder auf den kunstmarkt noch lassen sie
sich von kunstkritikern beirren
das macht ihre arbeit für authentisch
[Musik]
und wenn sie ins scheinwerferlicht des
erfolgs geraten bleiben sie doch sich
selbst das zeigt die geschichte von
pascal vonlanthen
[Musik]
pascal vonlanthen ist analphabet lesen
hat er nie gelernt
dennoch fasziniert ihn geschriebenes die
buchstaben malta ab und gibt ihnen
dadurch ein eigenleben
[Musik]
vor einigen jahren wurde der
kunstbetrieb auf seine buchstaben bilder
aufmerksam
die kunsthalle fribourg organisierte
2015 eine ausstellung der
ausstellungskatalog fand den weg in eine
new yorker buchhandlung dort wurde er
vom angesagten mode designer jason wo
entdeckt
[Musik]
der schuf 2017 eine kollektion nach
zeichnungen von pascal von lang
[Musik]
du weißt dass es new york und an anderen
orten leute gibt die dein t-shirt tragen
eine jeans weste deinen wollpulli dein
kleid weiß ich an den tagen an denen
pasqua von land nicht im creme ist
arbeitete er in der geschützten
werkstatt lafarre in fribourg
hier kaputt
[Musik]
das kommt den den ausschuss in den
ausschuss nach dienstschluss gibt es ein
paar muntere sprüche mit den kollegen
[Musik]
pascal vonlanthen stammt aus einer
bauernfamilie
sie waren sechs kinder davon sind vier
geistig behindert bis zum tod seiner
eltern lebte vonlanthen auf dem hof der
familie
die bäuerliche welt findet sich auch in
seinen zeichnungen
[Musik]
heute lebt er in einer betreuten
wohngemeinschaft sein zimmer immer schön
aufgeräumt
sie mögen die ordnung nicht wahr und die
sauberkeit und die sauberkeit
er begleitete ihn im alltag
sozialpädagoge eve aller scharia
und was hast du heute in der werkstatt
gemacht pascal ich habe säcke
kontrolliert wenn sie ein loch haben
muss man sie wegwerfen
aber es gibt nicht genug arbeit also
wenn es nicht genug arbeit gibt kannst
du bei mir arbeiten
was möchtest du kochen was braucht es
für die carbonara weißt du was ist in
der carbonara soße hat mehrere dinge
ich helfe dir für die soße braucht es
also gehen wir das einkaufen
ohne hilfe wäre der alltag für pascal
vonlanthen ein kaum zu bewältigen der
hürdenlauf
[Musik]
88 messer acht kabel auch im atelier am
sorgt er für ordnung hilft beim
aufräumen kümmert sich um das
wohlergehen aller das ist schön christel
du kannst es das nächste mal fertig
machen
du hast ganz schön geschuftet bist du
müde
[Musik]
danke